Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P I think sort of in reaction to
the Kanye West anti-Semitism controversy. I got
an interesting email. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, it's James again. I
was just wondering, do you think that most
anti-Semitism comes from people who don't know any
Jews? Cause I. I don't know a whole lot of Jews,
but the ones that I had met are really lovely
people. I'd say they're more Christ like.
Then probably more Christians than I met. Yeah.
So genius, because they don't know any Jews or
because they do know Jews and don't like them.
Speaker 1: What do you. So the thing about I've
met lots of people in my life who when they
find out I'm Jewish, they go, Oh, I've never
met a Jewish person before. It's almost always
they've never met a Jewish person that they were
aware of. But like most people, unless you
live in extremely rural places, you know,
certain parts of the country, it's just not
obvious. Like, you know, when you meet a black
person, you can tell that they're black. So when
people say, Oh, I've never met a Jewish person,
it's actually you probably just didn't realize
it. Now, for to this to this question is the
anti-Semitism, because these folks have never met
a Jewish person or they didn't like them. I don't
think it's related at all to personal experience
in many ways. For most of the folks that I've met,
it's based on stories that they heard over and
over and over again as they were growing up,
regardless of who they personally knew. That's
my that's my sense. That's my instinct. We have
a great bonus show for you today. Just me on the
bonus show today. Producer Pat, little bit under
the weather. He'll be back very soon. We will talk
about it's happening again. 40% of Republicans say
they will blame election fraud if they don't
win. They're already saying if we don't win,
we're going to blame election fraud. Also, big
problems for electric vehicle manufacturer Rivian,
who has had almost had to recall
almost all of their electric trucks.
Not good. And we will talk about upcoming debates,
the Spanish channel possibilities that are being
discussed and many, many more things. Get instant
access to the bonus show by signing up at join
pacman dot com. It's quick. It's easy. You can
use the coupon code. Big voting 22. The meaning
should be obvious as we are just weeks away from
the midterms. Big voting 22 at Joint Topics.